SPEAKER: Are your
applications deployed
in hybrid and
multi-cloud environments?
Anthos can help you
modernize your existing apps,
building new ones, and run
them anywhere securely.
Stay tuned to learn how to
get started with Anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Anthos 101.
Today, we will show
you how easy it
is to get started with Anthos.
Let's create our first
Anthos deployment.
In the Google Cloud
console, select
a project you want to work
in, or create a new one.
In the left navigation
menu, select Anthos.
Enable the API.
This may take a few
seconds, but when done,
you will see the
main landing page.
In the Getting Started section,
you can read the documentation,
create and register
your clusters,
and launch Anthos
sample deployment.
This is what we are going to
do today, so click and launch.
Now on the deployment
configuration screen,
you can select an
existing service account,
but since this is a
demo, we will just
create a new service account.
Leave the service account
name and ID as defaults,
and add a description.
And click Deploy.
While the deployment
is progressing,
the cloud console transitions
to the Deployment Manager view,
and after the sample is
deployed, in a few minutes,
you will see a green
check mark and can
review the full deployment.
You should see a list of
all enabled resources,
including the two Anthos GKE
clusters for prod and non-prod
and one compute engine
instance for the jump server.
And that's it.
You just deployed a
sample app in Anthos.
When you go back to
the Anthos dashboard,
you see service mesh card
and cluster status card.
Cluster status is
green, indicating
that the clusters are healthy.
You can click on each cluster
and know more about them
by navigating to Anthos GKE.
Within the clusters,
we can see the nodes,
and inside each node,
we can see the pod
summary and the details.
In the workload section,
you can see workloads
across all clusters.
Under services and
ingress section,
we have the Istio ingress
gateway service for the Anthos
sample cluster 1.
And ingress gateway
manages inbound traffic
for your application
service mesh.
And if we click on the external
endpoint using port 80,
we see our deployed
application in production.
Now, if we switch
back to the Anthos
and click on the
service mesh card,
we see all of our services
in the table view.
We can also switch
to topology graph.
Anthos service
mesh automatically
observes which services are
communicating with each other
to show service-to-service
connection details.
You can even drag and zoom
or hover over services
to see additional details,
including outbound QPS.
You can click on any
service to create SLOs.
Let's say we want to create
an availability SLO where
our shopping cart service is
99% available during a month.
There.
Our SLO is set up.
So we just deployed an
e-commerce application
using Anthos sample deployment.
Let's quickly review
the different components
that we have deployed.
There are two
Anthos GKE clusters
running on Google Cloud,
Anthos sample cluster 1
and sample cluster 2,
and the Anthos service
mesh deployed as separate
service meshes running
on both clusters.
We also have separate instances
of the online boutique
application deployed and
running on both clusters.
This is a web-based
e-commerce app
that uses a number of
micro-services written
in various
programming languages,
including Java, Go,
Python, and JavaScript.
And we had a Compute Engine
instance used as a jump server
for accessing resources in
our project in both clusters
and applying those changes.
What are you waiting for?
Start your Anthos journey today
using sample deployment as well
as the resources
linked below, and let
us know how it goes in
the comments section.
And for more Anthos and
Google Cloud content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]